hey what's up guys my name is Antonio
and welcome to episode 108 of game
programming so today we're gonna talk
about actually extracting our sheet
cells into individual sprites as you can
see we've got this to do here
it's the idea is I finished that font
rate this will be up for download
probably next episode because when I'm
actually going to use it in this episode
but I finished this are probably going
to add another row here and add more
symbols because we don't have anything
like square brackets curly brackets
backslash as false lashes we don't have
any of that stuff yet but this is what
it looks like right so we've got
uppercase and lowercase characters as
well as a bunch of symbols I'm gonna
talk more about this in the next episode
because that's what we're actually going
to implement at the font rendering but
basically just so you guys understand
our problem and you can understand
that's the solution for it we've got all
these different sprites right we want to
end what we actually want to render each
letter individually of course so our
problem here is that we want to extract
essentially each one of these letters
and each one of these symbols and
numbers each one of these characters we
want to extract into its own sprite okay
it needs to be its own sprite so that we
can render only it okay that is the idea
mmm so to do that we need to make a
method for that okay so we don't
actually have one I actually thought we
kind of did which is why last episode
I'm gonna just do the fonts of this
episode but we don't okay so we can
either implement this in this bright
class or the spritesheet class but
essentially what we need is an array of
sprites one thing I really like to do by
the way is um instead of just jumping
straight away into the sprite of the
spreadsheet class and and I guess
pulling and I guess you know just
starting to write the code for the
method there I'm actually gonna write
like what we want first right I'm
actually gonna write like the result
first of how I want to use this new
method to worry about a ride so I wanna
I want it to work like this right so we
want to have a private static sprite an
array of sprites here okay we can call
this characters mm will equal probably
something along the lines of sprite dot
split maybe I'll call it split and that
will be in charge of splitting that font
shape okay that is what I want in fact
let's probably do it in the in the
sprite class again because it does
return an array of sprites makes sense
so that's
the first thing I want to do so
literally right now I can just go create
a method okay but I'll do it for you
guys in case you're not using Eclipse if
you're using like sublime text or
something then you won't have that
obviously okay so over here under this
I'm gonna just put up public static
sprite the return types gonna be a
sprite array of course and I'll call
this split like I did before and all
it's gonna take in is this fried shape
all right
and that's it and it's gonna return
surprise let's start away let's just
type in sprite sprites and then return
sprites all right so it's right away
will will type in what we want to return
again this is tell your husband to
nationalise don't worry we'll initialize
it eventually anyway so basically let's
start writing this algorithm is gonna be
what another one of these algorithms
like we had in a sprite sheet like this
one here but it's gonna be a bit more
simple so don't worry anyway so first of
all we actually need to make a few
adjustments to this project class I was
looking through Azalea
we've got three variables here within
high now this is not the width of the
sprite sheet right this is the width of
the amount of sprites so this isn't that
that's one really important distinction
to make
so what I'm gonna do is I'm actually
going to make a public in oh sorry a
private private int and I'm actually
going to call it within high and one in
vector okay there's a lowercase so the
uppercase ones their public and their
final okay which means are there
constants that is the M that's the width
and height of each sprite okay in fact
it's the same as sighs if it's square
okay so if our sprites for example here
are sixteen by sixteen that is the size
of each character 16 by 16 pixels this
would be this would basically be 16 and
both of these would also be 16 that's
the idea right that's what it is
now what we want though is to actually
physically know how big this bright
sheet is in pixels okay we need to know
that how big it is
horizontally so the width and the height
okay vertically we want to know those
two we need to know that that we need to
know both of those pieces of information
so that's why I've made a width in high
this is gonna be the width and height of
the actual sprite sheet okay so down
over here and load where we actually
load the file I want to get rid of W and
H yeah I'm gonna get rid the
declarations and change this to be width
and this to be
hi so it's actually setting the fields
okay and then of course we'd have to
replace with over here where we have to
everywhere we have W before and then hi
as well okay
simple as that and that's it that's the
only change I'm making we need to make
it getter for that as well
so it'll simply be public and it get
width do we already have we don't have
anything like that so this is perfect
and that will return with all right and
then public and get high okay and that
will return high okay
and that's pretty much all we need to
know okay we just need to know the
actual width and height of the
spreadsheet that we're loading pixels
okay and then we could just pass in the
parameters here but then with that we
shouldn't have to write because
spreadsheet should know how big it is
that that's just one of the requirements
okay so the first thing we need to
evaluate now is essentially I guess the
amount of sprites okay that'll sprite
sheet doesn't contain that information
but we should know that information okay
so let's talk about how we can work out
how many sprites are in this bright
sheet using very very simple maths so
imagine you've a sprite sheet like this
okay
the width and height of this spreadsheet
is 32 by 32 and at the size of each
sprite as you can see it on the bottom
here is 8 by 8 pixels all right
so how can we work out how many sprites
are here if we just have the size of the
sprite and we just have the width and
height of the um of the actual
spreadsheet well what we can do is
pretty simple right we need to find out
how many pixels are in this sprite and
divided by having me so we have to fire
we have to figure out how many pixels
are in this spreadsheet and divided by
how many pixels are in the sprite or in
each sprite so we know a sprite shades
32 by 32 which is 1024 right if we
multiply those two together and then we
also know that each sprite is 8 by 8 so
8 times 8 is 64 right and if we divide
1024 by 64 we get 16 okay so we know
that there are 16 sprites here you can
you can obviously see it here it's four
by four but six in but that's how we
work that's how we can work out
mathematically so back to this now yeah
we'll make an amount variable so that is
the amount of sprites that we actually
need to create and we'll set this equal
to XI dot our width should get with
rises with they're not in um in pixels
and then we'll multiply that by shaved
off get hype ok and then we'll divide
this and I put this in brackets I don't
you don't really have to obviously but
just to make it easier to see and then
over here I'll simply put up the size of
each sprite all right which for us will
be a sheet dealt with times sheet height
okay I really should call this like
sprite width or sprite height or
something in fact I probably will just
because I'm I want to reflect this old
shift are just because it's um it's
probably hard to read okay so sprite
within sprite height simple as that this
should be equal to pretty much size if
our the thing is quite so I could have
put sprite size type of sprite size but
just in case in the future we want to
load sprites that are not square in then
we'll have to change everything so let's
just write it normally now okay and then
we'll set the amount of sprites that we
actually create will obviously be well
amount right that's how many sprites we
want to actually make so in our case it
would be what is this 13 times like 6
right what is that 13 times takes one is
a fifty to seventy eight I think
am i right there let's check six times
okay yep 78 so we want 78 we have to
return 78 sprites so that's in this case
amount should equal 78 okay
now what we want to do now is
essentially it's going to be made up of
four four loops okay so the first thing
we actually need though is a way to keep
track of
I guess the current sprite that we're
actually dealing with okay I'm actually
gonna write out the four loops first so
that he will be easier for me to explain
but essentially why pay is going to be
the Y position of the current sprite to
we're up to okay so this will simply be
sheet dot get with / sheet dot sprite
height okay
why
applause and then we'll do the same
thing for X XP XP support ender for XP
recently by the way their topic I guess
alright
not that I use XP or anything or Windows
XP but you know end of an era I guess
alright China so easily they basically
live on Windows XP anyway um so XP is
for sorry this should be shaped a width
what have I done here butchered that so
that should be um hi there should be
with okay great so what this is gonna do
is because since we're dividing my
sprite with this will be basically the
amount of sprites that there are
horizontally okay that's it yeah okay
pretty simple stuff so in other words
this number for our sprite sheet will be
like 13 okay because that's how many of
these there are okay and this this sorry
that's that's what XP will go up to XP
will go up to 13 why pay will go up to
six okay simple as that
it'll actually go up to five but you
guys get my point okay great so close
because it'll saw this error or from
zero to five now that we've done that
though we are we basically get to work
with the current sprite but what we need
to do now is read every pixel of that
sprite so to do that we have our y
equals less than simply sheet dot sprite
height right y plus plus and then the
exact same thing for X all right except
of course we're sending all these to be
X X and then sprite width and X all
right simple stuff now what we need to
do now is basically we didn't created
pixels variable right so in pixels these
are going to be the actual pixels of of
the act of the individual sprites so we
know this price is 16 by 16 right so we
can simply go ahead and set it equal to
shade dot sprite width times shaders
right high which my third should be 16
so 16 times extent of course will equal
how many pixels we have it our sprite
all right right sir
now we've done that we can basically set
pixels x plus y times sheet dot u s--
price width right equal to the extracted
pixels so just to see just to show you
guys what we're doing right I'm going to
resize this to like sixteen by sixteen
and then I'm going to generate a quarry
that husbands produces so this is a
single sprite yeah what we want to do is
we want to go into our file here right
and what we want to do is we want to
there's these for this for loop right
these two what they kind of do right is
they find out the index of where we are
so let's just say we're up to Q okay
the Y here would be one right and then
the X would be 1 0 1 2 3 to be 3 okay so
1 by this is a 3 by 1 right 3 comma 1
that is the corner of this now what we
need to do is we need to physically take
these pixels these 16 x 16 pixels and
pop them into their own pixel array and
then make a sprite out of that pixel
array that's our goal here so one thing
we have to realize is that you know how
I said these two this will be like up to
this will go all the way up to 5 from 0
to 5 this will go all the way from 0 to
12 right so 13 values for this and 6
values for this we need to actually
convert that into basically pixel
precision because this coordinate this
one being down 1 isn't gonna help us it
actually needs to be like ok 1 times 16
so we're down to 16 pixels start from
the 17th pixel essentially well the 16th
pixel of the first ones there alright
simple as that so to do that whoops
that's not the way that for loops to do
that we need to make some kind of offset
and I'll show you guys basically what
its gonna look like so we want to set
out we want to grab the pixels from our
sheet right and this will have to be get
pixels we want to grab the pixels from
our sheet and we want to read the
appropriate I guess version of those
pixels so X P times X right sorry X P
times
[ __ ] dot sprites width okay and then we
also need to add on excel actually have
the X on first
all right so X being the current pixel
that we're reading and XP x sheet then
climb sprite width will be the starting
horizontal pixel of the sprite okay now
because this is very long I'm actually
going to take this cut it and make two
variables so X low will be the X offset
that's the X offset Y offset will be
identical all right
but the idea is this finds mmm this will
simply find the current pixel that we're
reading from the sprite sheet so four
pixels is really easy because it's just
gonna be you know is gonna start from 0
but because the particular sprite we're
up to in this bright shade is not at 0 0
we have to figure out these offsets okay
now um here we'll just simply go X 0
plus y 0 x shades a dog yet width which
will get the width in pixels of course
alright great so let's do that now
what's up with this get pixels method
its undefined we don't have that okay
let's go open our sprites a class and
see what we've got here so we've got
yeah so we don't okay we don't okay
that's alright let's go ahead and make a
under the constructors here we'll go
public and in get pixels returned pixels
alright so we'll go to read only way of
getting pixels now fantastic okay that's
it that's pretty much it that's not
really it but that's pretty much it
what we need to do now is we need to add
these pixels we want to create a sprite
out of those pixels now okay how can we
do that well basically you know it's I
mean okay if we look at this product
class which is our current class you can
see that we have a way of actually
making a sprite out of simply pixels
yeah simple stuff okay
now
that's pretty much all we need to use
for this okay so after we've added all
of the pixels remember we don't want to
do it in the middle of the Foley we want
to add all of our outer add all of our
sheet pixels into this pixels variable
and then all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
hit up sprites now this is where it gets
interesting because what I want to do is
I want to hit up new sprite size and cut
out sorry not sizing Carla let's find it
for a constructor here pixels width and
height right that's the one that's the
only pixel thing we should have so
pixels and the width of course of the
actual sprite will simply be sheet dot
sprite width and then this will be shape
dots right height all right now this is
what I want to do this is one that this
is actually physically this bright
object I want to add to this right but
this isn't an ArrayList so I can just go
to add I actually have to know which
index in the array I want to add this to
so what we need is a manual way of
keeping track of which which which
element number which index were actually
up to so to do that we can actually just
make a variable for current okay this
will be the current sprite that we're
actually working with okay so over here
I'm gonna set sprites current equals new
sprite all right so the current sprite
that we're up to we will will actually
add to this well it will add a new
sprite based on these pixels to that
okay and then what I will do is we'll go
back up to this and it will deal with
the next sprite in our sprite sheet
extract all the pixels from it and then
add it into a new sprite all right I'll
keep doing that until we do it for the
entire sheet now one thing we need to do
is obviously increment our current index
right and we can do that by just simply
typing current plus plus what that will
do is Elvis bribe and basically add one
to current now to make this shorthand
you could just add the class class into
here okay what that will do is it will
look up the current the value of current
okay so for example zero for the first
one it will evaluate this expression
this new sprite stuff it will um it'll
actually you know run the constructor
for that whatever do what
we'll do whatever it needs to do and
then it will add that into the current
index of sprites and then it will
increment the current variable after its
added it okay if you do something like
the plus plus current right what that
will do is that will increment it first
so the first one will be zero oh the
first one will be one and then it will
actually set price equal to current so
we want to do it after obviously that's
why we put the plus plus after okay
anyway that is the idea okay
and then at the end of course we want to
just return sprites and we already got
that that's it that is the entire method
what that will do is extract every
single sprite in your spreadsheet into
into its own sprite and return that so
just to test that this works okay this
is already here
it's telling us we haven't use it but
that's alright what I'm going to do is I
want to make a new instance of the font
class in the in our main class okay and
we're gonna see because obviously when
the new instance gets created for the
first time it's going to run these two
static fields all right because they're
static so if we go to game okay there's
a win just verify case the fonts Arial
PNG is indeed I think it should be
I'd say fonts barrel up Andrew yep it is
indeed in here there it is
wonderful let's go ahead and go to game
and then I'll just you know maybe after
game start I'll just type in font font
equals new font now I think we're
actually using Java's font here okay so
I'm just gonna we're don't need this
anymore I mean that was just for the
mouth stuff so I'm actually just gonna
grab this card and and delete it okay so
this set College is gone all right go on
and then up here I'm gonna grab font and
just delete that as well the import and
now it'll tell us that it doesn't know
what font is so we can import our
version of it which is calm dr. channard
Reyna graphics tab bash not the java.awt
version okay and there we go that should
work now let's try and actually run this
okay I'm gonna hit the debug button mmm
I was actually expecting it to crash but
it didn't okay let's actually all one
thing okay one thing I did add actually
without telling you guys is inside the
sprite sheet I think that's where it is
yeah I added a system out of print life
things trying to load okay and that'll
actually tell us - okay let me just let
me go through this quickly and I'll show
you guys this is like a bonus page of
the episode the episodes done by the way
or if the only thing you guys want us to
know was on whether it loaded or not
then yeah you can even probably hit the
like button and then just get out but um
this is like a bonus little DVD extra so
I added a system out of front line that
says trying to load + path path of
course being whenever we said the
spreadsheet thing to path it will come
up here great so what I want to do is we
got this trying to load + path I'm
actually going to remove the Ln from
that okay and what I want to do is in
this cat block okay what I'll do is I'll
put in systems error dot print line and
then something like failed okay so it'll
be like trying load path and then failed
around then we can put like a new a
little your friend line so did we get
all right um and that what that's
actually what will happen if it fails to
load okay if it's successfully loaded
though you know we'll be fine I guess
okay so Beth yeah so what I mean is if
it's successfully loaded we actually
want to say that load successfully so
we'll put this up here this print line
and we'll just put like succeeded or
something in all right sorry just a
preview how this will work if I just
make this console a bit bigger so these
are all the is that all the spreadsheets
we're loading if I run this you can see
it says succeeded
I might actually add a like a dot dot
dot make this look a bit better it's all
about the aesthetics really but I
finally load this up it'll say it
succeeded for all this whereas if it
failed so if I miss belt Ariel put an S
in there or something I started this
it's actually didn't say failed for us
which is wonderful but let's go back to
let's go back to surprise shade
it okay it's because we didn't have this
thing if we actually run it there and
then go over here that's okay that's
interesting so it's it's generating an
exception in it okay I think that's part
of the reason we're catching an IO
exception here but I think what is doing
he is it's actually catching it's
actually generating an exception
initializer error and the reason it's
doing that by the way is because this is
static and it can't initialize the class
because we get an error
so probably we weren't really work in
this case but the idea is that if we
let's just say something that we don't
know that that's that's the only way
that we load
spry chase isn't it hmm interesting
interesting interesting interesting so
what we can do actually if we wanted to
to make it because it is throwing an
exception in July Sara what we could do
is simply add another catch block that
says if we catch an exception I don't
think we're using java 7 though I want
to say well using java 1.6 if we did
where we could do a multi catch but we
could do a catch exception initializer
right okay and then we could actually
put the failed into here and the sack
trace I mean we just keep that there
anyway okay so this is some errant live
failed again that's what happens if we
throw an exception initializer out so if
we run this what we should get okay well
right now everything succeeds but if I
go to the font and I misspell Arial or
something go back and spreadsheet run
this it will actually and cannot work so
there's a number of exceptions to get
thrown let's go ahead and just make it
exception okay and let's run that so now
you can see that what happens is it goes
trying to load all these things
succeeded and then at the end trying to
load fonts real there's no such thing so
it failed
okay so it tells us what gets loaded and
what doesn't this is a bit of a
debugging thing as well but that's
basically what I added and yes so I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of game
programming it is pretty long but next
time we're actually going to talk about
rendering text so by the neck by the end
of next episode 109 we should be able to
draw tax on to this right all right be
sure to hit the like button if you
enjoyed this and I will see you guys
next time goodbye
you